Here we go and three two one action and background action
Oh
Yes
Three two one action
Very nice
Uh
That makes sense
This unpredictable yet
Yeah
I loved creating the stunt sequences in this film. The action is explosive
This is an action movie, but it's also beautiful to look at
The film consists of a lot of fight sequences there's a lot of training and rehearsal involved
They were tremendously hard working is extremely exciting
I've had three months of training process. It's quite
Challenging six or seven hours a day. It's been really helpful. Yeah. I feel like I can do more push-ups
She's the best warrior amongst us
We get specific for the actors getting them up to speed from basic handling of weapons
All the way through to rolling falling running jumping that sort of stuff
We're doing a lot of stunt fighting sword training I feel like i'm training with like the best of the best
I've never ever had a six-pack in my life i'm starting to see some come through. So it's really really exciting
We had physical army style training. We also had stunts and martial arts horseback riding archery military marching
You name it all of the cast were brilliant and they trained hard
It's not just action for action sake it's all coming from character. And from story every action is very meaningful
Fire
the stunt sequences
Are epic. You've never seen anything quite so extraordinary in your life. We'll protect each other
We'll fight for each other
She's everything an action movie hero should be particularly when picking us with his sword
It is my duty to vote in order to bring this legendary story to life I had a huge vision for the live-action mulan
The film needed to be massive
Because this is an epic action adventure movie
Nikki understands the chinese culture and she loves mulan so she will bring to the world a very special hugo
And she also likes a big kick-ass movie
And that's what she's making
The way that nikki wanted to shoot the stunts was not in a rough and rugged way, but to be elegant and beautiful
Nikki sees the action through different eyes
She's really in tune with character development and how we use the action to drive the story
This story is epic and emotional
Ancestors, please protect her that emotional connection to her actors is nikki's forte
Nikki will push to the fine details of what she's looking for and take it to a very real place
Nikki is an actress director. She's really about the performance and that's what's most precious on screen
It's such an honor and a tremendous responsibility
To bring mulan to life in a new way
The world of mulan is so rich the costumes the colors the real landscapes and we've assembled the most
extraordinary cast of this movie
Led by lou yi faye
Nobody else could have played the role of mulan. She's a brilliant
Actress but that was only one part of the equation
We put her through a grueling physical assessment. She's an accomplished martial artist
Every moment yifei was on set. She raised the bar and she inspired
all of us
One of my favorite moments was shooting donnie yen's martial arts skills
As commander tong, he does a sword display in front of all of the recruits the way he moves a sword
It moves so fast. I had to shoot the sequence again in slow motion, just so I could see what he was doing
He is astonishing
This is a big vision of a big journey
And i'm so happy that we've been able to deliver
An epic vision of mulan's story. I will bring honor to us
All been a physical actor in action films and stuff but never training to this degree
This version of milan bori khan is our villain. He's played by
Jason, scott, lee and he has resurrected an army. That is so powerful. He intends to take the kingdom
Korikan's joined by a witch shenyang played by gong. Lee you will die pretending to be something you're not
The stunt choreography and design is incredible in this movie. We wanted to do something very different
The sword work and the stunt work, I think all those elements combined the preparation of it
All really helped me develop who or khan was destroyed
The witch is a human weapon
She's able to shapeshift into many things but most often the hawk her costume
Has walk details her weapons are on her body
The witch has supernatural element to her. So a lot of wire work involved which sort of blends in to create her overall style
I could tear you to pieces before you blink
It does feel epic and it does feel bigger than life
You really get a sense that these characters are from a different world
This movie's very real and very visceral as an action movie should be
It's going to be a wild ride
It's
Okay, thank you
Foreign
Okay
To eraser good thought